[Music]
a universal newsreel president harry
truman's state of the union address of
1952.
this was truman's last year as president
and his final state of the union speech
a joint session of congress welcomes
president truman as he arrives to
deliver his annual state of the union
message for 1952
the chief executive outlined his aims
for a solution of the korean problem and
a final armistice also plans for aid to
our needy neighbors
in addition to an encouraging report on
domestic progress and a plea for the
fair deal he specifically warned the
nation of threat of war and the
increasing build up of communist weapons
in spite of disarmament hopes
the present session of the united
nations in paris
we together with the british and the
french
offered a plan to reduce and control all
armaments
under a foolproof inspection system
this is a concrete practical proposal
for disarmament
if the soviet leaders were to accept
this proposal
it would lighten the burden of armaments
and permit the resources of the earth
to be devoted to the good of mankind
but until the soviet union accepts a
sound disarmament proposal
and joins in peaceful settlements
we have no choice except to build up our
defenses
the world still walks in the shadow of
another world war
to meet the crisis which now hangs over
the world
we need many different kinds of strength
military economic
political and moral
and of all these
i'm convinced that moral strength is the
most vital
when you come right down to it
it is the courage and character of our
nation
and of each one of us as individuals
that will really decide how well we meet
this challenge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you